let's jump to the story about uh Bud
Light
so we got this tweet from Ashley Saint
Claire
with this uh picture of Bud Light cases
of 24 packs with a rebate on them she
said the Bud Light marketing team must
still be all women if they think a
coupon will get a man's attention it's
very funny but then someone said rebate
and I think it's something like same
thing but if assuming this is true and
I've heard this from multiple people
already it says easy to drink easy to
enjoy get twenty dollars back via rebate
I don't know what the stipulations are
but if this is a rebate on a case of Bud
Light that would imply that
Anheuser-Busch is taking a loss on cases
of Bud Light to move product
I want to stress unconfirmed but I have
heard from numerous people they have
seen similar things personally in my
experience what I've seen is Major
discounts I was a liquor store a couple
days ago we were picking up it was
yesterday actually we're picking up
Gatorades to go skate and I was like
where the bud light ads and sure enough
they were big sales sale Bud Light huge
discount and some lady actually bought a
whole bunch
when I saw this I had to I had to wonder
with Bud Light sales dropping every week
for the past month and a half
Anheuser-Busch is thinking what can we
do to reverse those numbers several
things are happening they're not moving
products so they're not selling If the
product just sits there it goes bad
they're losing money they need to just
get rid of it if it's old get rid of it
so what do you do okay fine how about
free beer you buy it send in the rebate
we give you your money back effectively
making the beer free but giving them
sales metrics so next week when the
sales come out they'll say Bud Light
sales went up
don't do it I'm doing my part by shaming
people who buy Bud Light how do you
Shane them just boo them if you you saw
you hang out at a liquor stores
it used to hit on them you just ask them
like Hey where's the uh you know but
yeah so so I think I think the issue now
with uh with with Anheuser-Busch is that
they have created something that people
just don't want to be seen participating
in now let me let me jump to this next
story here we have this uh no that's the
wrong one where are we at here we go we
have this ad from Miller Lite looks like
Miller Lite has jumped into the woke
beer game so this ad started going viral
and uh I will now just uh play the ad
for you I suppose and then Grace you
with the the video
here's a little known fact women were
among the very first to brew beer ever
from Mesopotamia to the Middle Ages to
colonial America women were the ones
doing the Brewing centuries later how
did the industry pay homage to the
founding mothers of fear they put us in
bikinis
wait wait they put you in bikinis like
women don't buy bikinis they're forced
into them no we only buy them because
the patriarchy come on Tim no you don't
buy them they force you to wear them
that's true
wow like women don't like wearing that
look at this wild it's time beer made it
up to women okay here's here's my oh
sorry go to the beach a lot of money in
women buying beer that I don't know
about go to the beach and when you see
women in bikinis go I'm so sorry a man
made you wear that no that's normal I've
heard about this the only reason bikini
exists is
to dress for men and therefore the
patriarchy is making I don't know
unhappy well here's here's the rest of
the app so today Miller Lite is on a
mission to clean up just there's the
whole beer Industries
has been scouring the internet for all
this and buying it back so that he can
turn it into good for women Brewers
literally good
how you ask ladies take it away first we
turn the badge into compost now we feed
compost to worms pushed out beautiful
fertilizer
that good helps Farmers grow quality
hops
which has been donated to women Brewers
to make their own really good
but there's definitely more out
there in your attic in the garage in
your parents basement send any you
got into Miller Lite and they'll turn
that into good too
so here's to women because without us
there would be no fear
so so this is actually this is public
answer is
this might be a hot take Miller Lite is
actually doing a better service to women
in the sad than Bud Light with their
Dylan mulvaniad I guess we're saying
fair but also
yeah it's like whatever I guess like
they're trying to sell beer to feminists
or whatever like women don't bring back
the Super Bowl I'm sorry do feminists
buy tons of beer like is this like the
market industry that they have no no you
got it wrong the issue is they don't
they're trying to get them to that is
how this works at all well no the idea
is this the the marketing guys come in
they say hey women don't buy our beer
what do we got to do we gotta make a
more pro-woman beer the marketing guy
says here's our research showing you
what women want okay then let's do this
women's empowerment thing
I don't care about it let them do it I'm
just gonna tell you this are you are you
I will not drink the beer that comes
from these women Brewers because it was
brewed garbage that's literally what the
ad says the ad says they're taking
magazine clippings newspaper and old
cardboard cutouts composting it down to
grow vegetables with I don't like it
when my food comes from garbage I like
it when my food comes from like for like
normal fertilizers and like the Earth to
put it simply if you take a bunch of
magazine clippings that are full of inks
and other chemicals and then compost
them and grow things from that I kind of
feel like that will leech into the
product you're consuming and I don't
even like plastic bottles so uh yo I'm
not gonna buy you're telling me not to
buy beer from women who brew beer
because you're giving them garbage hops
yeah also they're donating them to women
women need extra help brewing beer so
we're gonna send them extra materials
like how could anyone like this ad I
just don't get it at all I understand
what you're saying they're trying to say
I love it now women it will be
empowering if you drink PR because
really the real feminist drink is beer
and I think that is clever if not
affected it's it's the dumbest thing in
the world because the it is constantly
telling women I just don't get it it's
like they're it's it's like the
establishment is constantly telling
women the best way to be a woman is to
try to be like a man drink the drinks
that men drink go to work like men sleep
around like men want to what the hell is
going on like why is it that Society
keeps telling women just be like dudes
well no they're like be like us
feminists join our cult be a feminist be
a feminist be a feminist be a feminist
that's the only thing you ever hear uh
with women's movements it's always about
being a feminist you never hear the
other angle there are very few Outlets
that are saying like be feminine Embrace
traditional roles all guys want you to
be feminine except that you are
different from men and therefore you
have different talents and skills like
instead it's like no no no now we gotta
get into the beer industry even if you
don't like it drink a beer put those
shelters down like I just don't
understand how this is appealing who
cares if women made beer a hundred
thousand years ago I don't I'm not gonna
drink it if I don't want to and you
selling magazine fertilizers or donating
to women like it's it's it reminds me of
Tom's shoes they're like oh but it's
important because we give a shoe away
and so therefore you feel good like if
they're trying to get all of these
arguments to make women drink beer I
really think we should just stop make a
different product for women they don't
want to drink beer that's okay girls
leave them alone peach bellinis are
better anyways and if you like and
you're a lady that's great don't drink
this beer though
literally literally this is the same
woman that was advocating for women to
grow their armpit hair out oh yeah oh
good yeah I don't know her name but
whoever they tapped for this ad
there's a secret ingredient in this uh
stop being like women like now all of
you have to go to a bar and buy a woman
whatever type of beer this is and be
like here a Miller Lite I got this
because I believe in women it's now I
respect the women so I will buy Norway I
just assumed you wanted a Miller Lite
did you know that women brewed beer if I
really don't like women I'll be getting
a bunch
like I just like I just don't understand
why the at like all of the
advertisements that you see are trying
to get women to be more like men I think
and trying to get married to be more
like women like unless there's a secret
society of female beer drinkers who have
tons of money that that's untapped by
this Market stop well no but that's
that's but I think you misunderstand
like they're trying to get new people to
buy their products I don't think it will
be an effective conversion rate I think
they're better off investing that
marketing money in a product that women
are actually already buying
I I disagree with that I think any any
company that's selling a product is
asking itself what can we do to get our
product in the hands of of the opposite
sex so like Bic Razors for instance
they're like men shave their faces can
we sell this product to women sure they
shave their legs and armpits let's
promote that idea and then they run an
ad campaign saying shave your armpits
yeah but that's that Bud Light launched
the Seltzer initially when there was the
Seltzer craze they launched filter
because they're like more women drink
the Seltzer so we'll make them a
specific product that is under our
umbrella they did not see a sudden rise
of people running to Bud Light they just
decided that at some point they were
going to make them their target audience
I just don't think that's effective
what's not effective about it is
insulting men and women to run an ad if
like they did that commercial with that
guy miles what's his face and his wife
and they're like dancing and drinking
Bud Lights together that's how you
Market to women
not this
not Dylan Mulvaney that just offends
people
I can't I just can't even imagine Dylan
Mulvaney being uh compelling to women I
can't see this being compelling but I
know there are women who'll be like what
no
started brewing beer first and then men
took that from us and they will feel an
outrage like they're playing instead of
on well we're talking about the I don't
remember the actor but he's a top gun
that ad is aspirational right you're
like with your man and you're having fun
and it seems fun like women want that
they want to Aspire up right this one is
saying like be resentful and bitter and
buy our beer and I just don't want to
live a life like that that's a good
point that's not the reason you want to
drink a beer yeah they're just trying to
Market you being unhappy and I feel like
that's a negative spin here Miller Lite
yeah yeah I mean I I just I don't see I
don't see it really converting a lot of
people I don't see a compelling you know
also are they just like assuming their
male audience is going to be all male
feminists and be like oh man cool we'll
keep buying this to support the women
great bait for social media though
whoever made that ad did this this was
this was old and this was actually ran
or was it okay yeah nobody cared yeah
and I gotta be honest I still don't care
like people are calling for a boycott of
Miller and I'm like why I mean look
don't drink the garbage beer like that I
get if you go to if you go to like a
women Brewery this is the problem now if
I ever go to a bridge like women owned
I'm gonna be like did you get hops from
Miller because like I don't want
magazine clipping chemicals in my beer
you know I don't know maybe the plants
filtered out but look we've got septic
tank out here with the leech field
anybody who has septic knows about leech
Fields it's where it runs off and uh
they tell you not to grow things there
because you know it's gross they tell
you not to but if you watch the way the
Grass Grows above your leech field
compared to the other places you know
you're mowing that
want to get out there like well actually
the lions are crazy it's probably it's a
lot of water yeah but you know like
generally don't eat vegetables because
it's absorbing a lot of the stuff that's
coming up there I think the same thing
is true if they're taking magazine
clippings from the 80s or whatever and
then composting it and then trying to
make beer out of it that like I'm just
not into that just sprinkling lead paint
in while they're at it they're like it's
fine so now you have a guy and it's like
I like going to this Brew because I'm by
women but you know she gets her hops for
free from Miller and it's made of old
newspaper clippings I'm not I don't want
to drink that I think it's weird that
they're pretty negative it's like a
local Brewers thing we're gonna help
local lady Brewers by giving them our
multi-million dollars
hey that's what they are right like
apparently that matters you know or is
it just you only change it when it's men
it'd be men Brewers and they would just
be the Brewers because they started it
remember women started to brewing beer
before anyone could think of it back in
ancient Mesopotamia apparently thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time